[Musique]
l'opéra de paris un monstre assemblage
de doigts de coupoles de steak
autour du grand dôme de cuivre pour un
chéneau une sorte de boussières si large
et si profonde que l'on pourrait y faire
naviguer un canot depuis l'édification
du dôme
personne n'était jamais remonter dessus
c'est la première réparation
philippe remonter à ratier l'eau
oui alors ça on les dépose parce que
toute l'ossature en fer était rouillé il
descendait y tombe est tombée alors on a
dû les défaire les pièces qui font de
102,5 kilomètres de près les déceler les
sens et les porter en atelier pour les
réparer intérieurement leur refaire une
santé
[Musique]
et leur désarroi face et décoration
pendant tout autour voyez tout autour la
rage on appelle ça un peu des tranches
de melon est alors cessé dans les deux
longs sont disons se raccrocher sur des
boutons qui sont dans lundi dans la
charpente faire et c'est la première
fois qu'on les a en fait eu la
construction
je crois que j'arrêtais sa première fois
d'ailleurs il en avait quelques-uns qui
tombait qui s'affaissait dans de chez
nous
[Musique]
voilà
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]